president Trump has hit the campaign
Trail and he has identified a new nasty
woman you know he brought up that phrase
first against Hillary Clinton quite
aptly now he's turning that phrase on
Megan Kelly
I sat down for an hour and then I did a
Megyn Kelly one and she had you know
just well she became nastier all of a
sudden she was pretty nasty didn't you
think anybody that watched it
I don't think she was particularly nasty
and more more to the point you know look
president Trump he's a good campaigner
he's a once in a generation political
Talent so far be it for me to criticize
his strategy that has worked
unexpectedly well for a long time now
but this seems to me a misstep
take aside any moral consideration take
aside that I'm friends with Megan Kelly
take a side that I think she conducted
the interview in a very fair way just as
a tactical matter
if if I'm Donald Trump if I'm on the
Trump campaign
I I think I've got a notice Megan Kelly
is not the enemy even though there was
that that spat back in the 2016 campaign
even though Megan Kelly did ask him a
very tough question during the debate
said you've called women fat and ugly
and stupid and whatever and and Trump
had the unbelievably brilliant answer
which was only Rosie O'Donnell probably
the moment that he locked up that race
just so fast on his feet so funny but in
this case
Megan Kelly has been very fair to Donald
Trump for many months now she's been
predicting for a long time that he's got
the presidential
nomination locked up I don't think she
connected conducted the interview in a
in a bad way and I just think there's a
principle in politics which is the
conservation of enemies you know you
don't want to grow your enemy list too
long and in this case I don't think
Megan is a fair enemy I made this
criticism of the DeSantis campaign when
I I felt that their online campaign was
just harassing and going after people
who were winnable who were potential
allies who at least were being fair and
were not were not the enemy
and I think that the same principle
holds true here maybe it doesn't matter
for Trump because he's just so far up in
the polls that he can afford to expand
his enemies list a little bit
but generally speaking I I think
tactically this is kind of a misstep
he's on the precipice of locking up the
nomination entirely the interview
basically was fine for him even though
he kind of whiffed it on a couple of
questions I don't think it really is
going to upset his standing in the polls
seems Seems needless to create an enemy
where there is not one right now go to
geniusell.com knowlesyt as you might
know we are all big fans of genucel over
here but you don't just need to take my
word for how great a company it is Ella
from Rockford says quote I have both age
and acne spots and this stuff is
actually fading both of them this Serum
is worth every penny Ella is raving
about the famous Dark Spot Corrector
from geniusell a must-have after months
of record heat and humidity sunspots
brown spots discoloration even red
inflamed patches all disappear in front
of your very eyes here's the genucel
amazing guarantee you will see results
on day one or your money back so take
advantage of geniusell's most popular
package which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic geniusell
bags puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all at about 70 70 percent off
so you can try the best skin care in the
world for yourself completely risk-free
it is simple go to geniusell.com
knowlesyt letter y letter T start
looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
crow's feet at genucel.com knowlesyt
that is genucel.com
Knowles YT hello Michael Alex here again
long time listener huge fan currently
about to finish my conversion
Catholicism thank you to you being a big
part of that and leading me to that and
just the truth of the one true church so
thank you so much anyway here's my
question so a discussion I get it
frequently with one of my Protestant
friends is the Immaculate Conception
I've I I somewhat understand it and I'm
trying to listen to many people like Dr
Tony Marshall explain it who's much more
intelligent I am but I would just love
to hear your elevator pitch or your kind
of dumbed down version if you will for
somebody like myself of how to how do I
not only how do I explain this and fully
understand the Immaculate Conception of
Mary how is it that even though the
Bible says that all of sin and fall
short of Glory of God how do I explain
this a Protestant that Mary was sinless
said she she really was Hail Mary full
of grace and sinless so thank you so
much Michael Kaling for your answer God
bless well you just partially explained
it right there
which is the Full of Grace part but for
those who don't know the Immaculate
Conception refers to the conception of
Mary without the stain of original sin a
lot of people think it refers to the
Virgin birth you know or the conception
of our Lord Jesus Christ without a human
male participating but it refers to the
conception of Mary and so this raises a
problem in the minds of some people
which is well hold on I I was told that
all sin and fall short of the glory of
God so that's got to include Mary too
right because that that's literally what
it says
but if we were to interpret that verse
in the most strict literalism we
possibly could then we would have to
conclude that our Lord Jesus Christ
sinned and fall fell short of the glory
of God because he is among the set of
all
he's a person
right so did Jesus sin no of course not
that's absurd
all sin and fall short of the glory of
God is a true statement about Mankind
and human nature but
our Lord Jesus Christ is obviously an
exception to that rule and the Blessed
Virgin is an exception to that rule too
does this mean that Mary didn't need a
savior no certainly not the Immaculate
Conception is a Catholic dogma but it's
a it's been a belief of Christians since
time immemorial uh which is that Mary
was preserved from the stain of original
sin by a singular and special Grace of
Jesus Christ so it is it is
still that Jesus Christ sacrifice on the
cross is what redeems mankind but that
there's a special ordering of that in
the case of Mary one way to describe it
would be if you fell into a ditch and
then I come along and I pull you out of
the ditch I saved you from the ditch
right but if you were walking toward a
ditch and I said hey hey
step around that there's a ditch there I
also would have saved you from the ditch
but it would have saved you from the
ditch before you fell into the ditch
which is what our Lord did to his mother
uh part of the reason for this is that
as Christ is the new Adam Mary is the
new EVE uh and both created without
original sin uh part of this is because
Eve is the new
Ark of the Covenant Covenant Christ is
the New Covenant and Mary is the new ark
of the covenant and the Ark of the
Covenant is immaculate stainless but we
also see this in scripture too which is
when uh well as you say hail Mary Hail
Mary full of grace the Lord is with thee
this phrase full of grace is not hey
you're partially with race it's that
you're full of grace and then you see
this in the greeting from Elizabeth to
Mary which is she says blessed are you
among women and blessed is the fruit of
your womb Jesus so this same
word
juxtaposed right next to one another to
refer to the blessedness of Mary and the
blessedness of our Lords it is a
singular type of blessedness and then
you just have 2000 years of the
Christian tradition so if you say well
that doesn't really convince me Michael
I'm not persuaded uh you know that's
you're just reading parts of scripture
or you're just uh deducing certain
things by reason
um but you know that's not really what I
believe where is it in scripture more
directly or something I guess I would
just have to ask why is it that
Christians have believed this for two
thousand years and then in more recent
centuries people stopped believing this
that's why I just would always ask the
question of History why one's views
which are supposedly so ancient or out
of line with history and then I would
ask the question of authority
uh when people say well I just read my
Bible and I know what it means you say
well a lot of people read the Bible and
they have all sorts of varying
interpretations so so you haven't
sidestepped the question of authority
who has the authority
of interpretation in the interpretive
principle and even if you don't
believe in the pope yet or something you
know even if you don't believe in the
the authority of the church you might at
least believe in the authority of the
vast majority of Christians who have
lived going back to the apostolic age
boy what a great clip that was now
before you go make sure you ring the
bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time